do you miss performing do you miss it at
all or is it like nope that was that was
fun done with that yeah I mean I think
it's it it it it does
feel uh like it's it's uh it's hard to
it's hard to say I guess I guess maybe a
little bit but it's just kind of
starting I mean I did that run with ke
and Peele really was getting to do
everything and that came at the end of
like you you've been out there for a
while you've been doing improv you're on
Mad TV so you you had been working it
for a while before people really got to
know you in yeah I was I was slinging
rock in a um sketch comedy form on Mad
TV yeah you know and and then of course
my entire sort of what was meant to be a
collegiate career was dedicated to
improv and sketch in Chicago and
Amsterdam M so I feel like I no I I I
you scratch that itch what I get to do
now is just more fun just more fun yeah
well also I mean you're creating worlds
which is just I mean what could be
greater than that I mean I'm I'm you
know to and to be to
be uh fair and and clear it's
like there's there's something that's
possible when you have have this as you
know this privilege of working with this
enormous team of people who are like
okay I'm I'm on board with your vision
let's go yeah and there's something that
is just you know that's just uh you feel
like okay this it's not about me anymore
it's about this thing we can we've built
and we're building and these things that
we're going to build it it's it's hard
to look back at all that time especially
because like like 300 short films short
comedy films if I wanted to do one again
I got to do it again and ultimately I'm
not I'm I'm I'm sick of watching myself
and so I don't know what you're talking
about yeah you get
it I know it is really funny we all of
these cameras on here are just on him
yeah yeah we're not we don't even have
your mic on this is just we're going to
later try and remember what it is you
said all right
uh I'm going to read over we have a
transcript of what you said it I'm going
to read it back right
well just the that's the creepiest idea
yeah a guy has uh lost his mind to that
degree but uh that's that's Alex Jones
right didn't know but he was we're
working our way towards that format we
just have to yeah we'll get there don't
you wor guys it's a corporate move came
from up top so um I'm curious what's it
like now you're in this position where
you are getting to meet these directors
these people that made your childhood
helped form your
sensibility do you have an easy time
walking in and going hey how are you or
do you get a little self-conscious
around people like that it depends who
and um it's not
necessarily uh it's not
necessarily a one toone who is is you'd
think would be easy to talk to I
remember meeting Michael
man and you know you always hear he's
kind of gruff and you know who there all
kinds of stories can predate meeting
somebody I just felt he was so kind of
warm connected
cool and um and I and and so I I had no
nerves uh talking to the guy yeah Paul
Thomas Anderson you know he's a good
friend of mine I've I've spent a lot of
time with him and I'm still very nervous
around him so it's what's weird yeah you
know cuz he's just that cool he
is do you get to call him PTA I'm like
Pete PT yeah PTA no yeah I do I think I
have called him cuz Sandler's friends
with him he's always going he's always
saying things like hey con calls me cone
hey since SNL days but he sticks with
that and he goes like hey con yeah I
just had uh you know I'm having a
sandwich with PTA and I'm always
remembering like wait
you're parent teacher
I'm like oh I forgot I'm not cool but
yeah another you forgot for a second I
just I'm sorry I forgot I was because
you actually have lunch with the parent
teacher associ when I yeah and I'm
disappointed when Paul Thomas Anderson
shows up no no one says Paul Thomas
Anderson anymore no one says that
anymore people say PTA okay well guess
I'm not didn't get the memo my whole
life if I remember write an autobiograph
it's like I didn't get the memo no by
the way he would he would disagree with
me by the way way on the record I think
he would I think he' say no please yeah
call me Paul probably yeah probably I'll
stop speaking for him he he does a
pretty good job yeah I just uh now where
are you in the midst of working on your
next film uh I mean you probably can't
say anything about it but where I I
don't even understand how your process
works do does an idea come to you and
then it just percolates for a while how
does it happen yeah I mean this has been
a obviously an interesting year because
uh the writer strike has had me sort of
in a a a state of um listening y you
know and uh that's kind of where I've
needed to be and I I I do feel like you
know my next project is um is is clear
to me and and I'm I'm I'm psyched to to
that that I have another film that you
know it could be my the could be my
favorite movie if I make it right that's
awesome can't wait can't yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah that's very cool I could be
totally bullshitting you guys right now
and you guys I can't wait yeah well I'll
be comped you'll have to pay yeah well
we'll do it we'll just I'll get my yeah
we'll uh no they should you want them
them to they pay why don't you just pay
for us and then cuz I'd like to go for
free with
PTA as my plus one I know that that
that's on offer I don't know that that's
on offer thank you Jesus have you talked
this was going so well this is one I
love this discussion and then I I you
pushed it too far I pushed it too far
that's on me I'm going to look at the
tape later and go like yeah that's the
part that was the moment that's the ruin
moment I ruined
it